[Música]
y llegamos directo hasta chile ahí está
nuestra corresponsal en santiago
patricia luna patricia la saludo muy
buena mañana del lunes por supuesto
vamos a hablar de esta entrega de la
redacción de la nueva constitución al
presidente gabriel boric patricio usted
está ahí
a pocos metros de distancia de lo que
era el antiguo congreso chileno en la
capital como es el ambiente que dicen
los chilenos
buenos días en este lunes tranquilo por
el momento en las inmediaciones del ex
congreso como tú muy bien señaladas
donde nos encontramos en la plaza de
armas las personas se acuden a su
trabajo está todo vallado y ya comienza
el proceso la ceremonia la llegada de
las autoridades que van a presenciar
este hecho histórico en el que la
convención constitucional exactamente un
año después de haber comenzado su
trabajo entrega el texto de una nueva
constitución un texto de trescientos
ochenta y dos artículos que ha sido
polémico en el camino también en cómo se
ha gestado y que llega hoy a su fin con
la entrega al presidente a partir de
aquí habrá dos meses para trasladar este
texto a la ciudadanía para que los
ciudadanos chilenos entiendan bien
cuáles son los cambios que implican este
nuevo texto constitucional respecto al
que rige en la actualidad que recordemos
trata de la dictadura de augusto
pinochet del año 1980 y para que después
tomen una decisión informada con la que
votar en el plebiscito de salida
previsto para el próximo 4 de septiembre
patricia pero hagamos un recorrido de
cómo ha sido este proceso hasta llegar
al día
no un año de la redacción de esta nueva
carta magna que pues obviamente falta el
voto final de los chilenos el próximo 4
de septiembre pero como ha sido todo
este recorrido
bueno son 154 finalmente en los
convencionales que han escrito este
texto partieron sin 255 uno de ellos se
metió en el camino en un proceso en el
que también era difícil de emitir porque
no estaba previsto porque había mentido
sobre la razón que le había llevado a
ser elegido ha sido un proceso lleno de
vaivenes de idas y vueltas de muchas
polémicas la ciudadanía está un poco
molesta con ciertas actitudes de algunos
convencionales a los que se ha tildado
de arrogantes oa lo mejor de no atender
un poco las demandas ciudadanas una
pugna importante entre la derecha que
por primera vez no tuvo un 30 por ciento
en
una institución de poder y por tanto no
pudo vetar las cosas que quería vetar y
un texto constitucional en el que si le
pasa pasaría a hacer de un estado
subsidiario a un estado garante de
derechos con mucho foco en los derechos
sociales también en temas
medioambientales una constitución de
nuevo siglo que fue elaborada de forma
paritaria que también tiene el tema de
género y los derechos digitales por
ejemplo presente en su texto